you're gonna go to sleep you're going to
start snoring and then you're going to
pass away quietly later today one of the
inmates in this prison will be put to
death I'd say over 32 people that I've
executed I'd say probably 20% the people
will say you're executing an innocent
man an execution in America is still
relatively common what's different about
this case is that the condemned man
didn't kill anyone I've never been in
trouble in my life with the law with
anybody we're in the best country in the
world how can this happen in this
country Richard Glossip is 52 and has
spent 17 years on death row protesting
his innocence death is different you got
to make sure it's beyond the shadow of a
doubt and he's got some high-profile
supporters he's a perfect example of
what's wrong with the death penalty but
the state of Oklahoma says he will die
Richard Glossop's attorneys have had
ample opportunities to make all the
points and all the arguments we heard
today they've all been rejected multiple
times
and so the execution will go forward for
eight months I've been following the
Curious Case of a man who's about to be
executed for a murder which someone else
committed Richard Glossip is an inmate
at Oklahoma State Penitentiary we speak
regularly on the phone but we've never
met until now I want to meet him face to
face because he's asked me to be a
witness at his execution I didn't commit
this crime and there is no down my line
then I may die because of this it's
January 1997 and the owner of Oklahoma
City's best budget in has been found
dead in room 102 barry van Treece was
beaten to death with a baseball bat his
motel was often used by drug addicts and
prostitutes but the man who killed him
was a 19 year old handyman who lived and
worked there in this police interview
Justin Sneed confesses to the crime but
encouraged by the detectives he agrees
someone else was involved we think we
know this is all more than just you okay
you know everybody saying you're the one
that did this you did it by yourself oh
please that
Sneed said that the motel manager
Richard Glossip paid him to do it and
agreed to testify against him in return
for a lighter sentence he went to jail
Glossop was convicted of murder and
sentenced to death
edie Blau worked in the district
attorney's office at the time of gossips
trial people are convicted of murder and
other crimes all the time based on
accomplished testimony based on
circumstantial evidence I mean that's
what the law is in the United States
however when you're giving somebody the
ultimate punishment we've become
accustomed to there being more of there
being a confession there being videotape
evidence there being a mountain of
evidence and in this particular case if
you're looking at through the lens of
the death penalty the evidence does not
seem to be substantial enough to warrant
that and I believe that's why it's
getting the scrutiny it is just like a
dead man walking Susan Sarandon is
fighting to get one man off death row in
recent weeks the case has been getting
huge publicity much of it is down to the
involvement of the actress Susan
Sarandon and an interview she gave to
Sky News in July bad representation two
trials that were ridiculous I mean he's
a perfect example of what's wrong with
the death penalty and so of course I'm
hoping that some kind of exposure will
give him the opportunity to maybe you
know get his sentence at least commuted
because he's clearly innocent
the actress won an Oscar for her role in
the movie dead man walking
she played sister Helen Prejean a nun
who works with death row prisoners here
they are together in one scene sister
helen is now 76 but still active against
the death penalty she agreed to be
Richard Glossip spiritual advisor and
we'll be there when he's executed he
always asked me
sister Helen what do you think is really
gonna happen on the 16th and I say to
him sometimes I'll feel like I'm Peter
walking on water in the Gospel story I
say to him Richard you are not going to
die these are from January till now well
until and this case does seem to attract
a lot of public support from around the
world these are some of the letters and
cards which have been sent to him and
which he reads and replies to before
passing them on to his niece for
safekeeping and in these three guys
would have been in your side one from
Britain reflected his favorite TV show
last of the summer wine does it bring
any comfort seeing all these letters and
seeing these people who who want to yes
it does it means that we're being heard
and people are seeing for themselves
that he's innocent and this is helping
him to have his positive outlook every
day knowing that people do care if the
worst comes to the worst in September
the 16th comes around and the governor
hasn't intervened and no new evidence is
emerged what do you do what are you
doing the day is pray
that it's quick and just peaceful
the governor of Oklahoma has the power
to grant a 60-day stay of execution more
than a quarter of a million people have
signed an online petition but Mary
Fallon refuses to do so or meet
campaigners herself we heard a lot about
Richard Glossip and when he's going
through right now there is a real victim
in this case it's very Vint Reese who
was beaten to death in his sleep
it's his seven kids and it's his wife
and we have heard from members of his
family who are satisfied with both the
verdict for Richard Glossip and the
Justice of his death sentence Barry Van
Teresa's Widow Donna had agreed to an
interview with me but then canceled
without explanation this is what she
told an Oklahoma TV reporter last
January when Richard Glossip had his
original execution date postponed
sure there's anger there you know
there's anger that you want it to be
over with you want this part to be
finished you want to be able to take a
breath and to carry on knowing that
justice has been served
I'm truly sorry for what happened Barry
I am but I had nothing to do with it I
truly had another I would not have heard
Barry in any way shape or form and I
surely would have had somebody else do
it for me
the prosecution said Glossop wanted van
Treece dead because he feared he was
about to be fired from his job and they
pointed to suspicious behavior when van
Treece was reported missing he initially
failed to tell detectives that Sneed had
admitted to him he'd murdered their boss
I made some really bad decisions after
the fact I'm not saying I did but I
think I paid for them with 17 years of
my life that interview was conducted
last November by Fox 25 reporter Phil
cross the prison authorities have
refused to allow me or anyone else
another chance to talk to him on camera
he comes across as very genuine and I
believe that he definitely believes in
his innocence it's not the first time
that an Oklahoma execution is under
close scrutiny
last year inmate Clayton Lockett took
three-quarters of an hour to die
focusing more attention on the method
used to kill prisoners routinely looking
for options earlier this year Glossop
appealed to the US Supreme Court to stop
the execution not on the basis of his
innocence but that the drugs used in
lethal injections caused unnecessary
suffering the court turned him down five
to four few people in America have
witnessed as many executions as Randall
workman for 10 years he was the warden
at Oklahoma State Penitentiary he's
watched 32 people male and female being
put to death I have had some individuals
that were being executed that was very
nurturing to us you know and said I'm
going to go to heaven don't worry about
me everything is just fine I have had
some individuals that told me you're
going to you're going to go to hell you
are you are you are committing murder
yourself were you never worried that
mistakes could be made and that an
innocent man was being executed I hear
the stories and I see the shows were the
DNA has proven that a person was
wrongfully committed can I say it's
possible yes
yes I can say that it's possible do I
personally feel like that I've executed
somebody that is innocent I'd say it's
not for me to say
there are 3,000 inmates on death row in
America
48 of them in Oklahoma Richard Glossip
will be the first to be executed here
since June Supreme Court ruling on
lethal injection he's had many lawyers
over the years but dawnlight is the
latest to try to find some new piece of
evidence which could save his life the
governor's office would say and have
said why do you need 60 days you've had
18 years to try to gather all this
evidence why has it been left until
these last few months I haven't had 18
years to do the work that I would do as
mr. Glossop's lawyer I saw the work that
the other lawyers have done in this case
and I think quite frankly they should be
ashamed in themselves
there wasn't any work done there wasn't
any investigation done this was a
one-sided fight at the government waged
against mr. Glossop and they got what
they wanted and there have been
approaches to the killer Justin's need
to try to get him to recant the evidence
that put Glossop on death row yeah I
wrote Justin a letter and I met with him
yesterday
the nature of what we talked about was
confidential because I went in as the
capacity as a spiritual adviser and just
understanding that he was a 19 year old
kid under a lot of pressure and I've
actually gotten him a lawyer a very good
lawyer to help him through whatever
steps he's going to take
but time is almost up today at 3 o'clock
you'll be taken to the death chamber and
yet just over a week ago when I visited
him he remained upbeat his family don't
want to watch him die so we'll hold a
vigil outside the prison when it happens
but they believe he's now accepted his
fate
yeah he's accepted it and he's at peace
with it he's going heals no grudges
against anyone and like he said he just
wants to die happy I'm not going to let
this break me down and take away the
spirit that I have nbe or the soul that
I have in me my main goal to make sure
that the whole world knew that I was
innocent and that's why when you came up
to visit me you saw you know that I
laugh a lot I smile a lot I smile all
the time
because that's me anyway I've always
been that word he said an extraordinary
phrase he said he's going to dance to
the death chamber when I looked at him
and I said you're going to have to
explain that phrase otherwise people are
gonna think you're crazy and he said
well I'm not gonna literally dance there
but you know I'm gonna walk in there and
I'm gonna be fine I'm gonna walk on to
the into the death chamber and I'm going
to sit down on the gurney of my own free
will and it's going to be the happiest
execution they've ever seen this is a
man who still maintains his innocence
but it's more important for him to clear
his name in the court of public opinion
it seems even though the courts in
Oklahoma convicted him of murder
you